I want to sit on Daniel Ezra's face
period
what what
[Music]
s up everybody my name is Michael Evans
Bailey I'm Samantha Logan and I am
Daniel Ezra
and today we are here to read uh this
tweet this is going well and we're from
All American we are from online let's
read some tweets shall we yeah Daniel
Ezra makes me think nasty thoughts
okay I want to
do a good stop okay Samantha Logan is on
the list of women I would drop
everything for her she's so bad why are
you not in your hair
that's nice that's cool that's like no
that's very nice that's super sweet
thank you appreciate that the way I
would drop out of college without even
attending first just to date Michael
Evans building that's very endearing
stay in school but also get your degree
if I had to kiss Samantha Logan that
much and not fall in love with her yeah
sounds insane to me it's actually pretty
easy
a big old L for me you know I feel the
same way Michael Evans Bailey can slap
across the face I'm assuming you meant
to say me across the face and I'd thank
him finally silent okay come on let's
move on to be honest
if Daniel or Ezra came at me I'd give
him a baby I swear
came at you
oh
minor intense
oh my God mine are like life-changing
like
you guys I literally have the biggest
crush on Samantha Logan it's the full
name for me it's really funny like I'm
talking about twirling my hair and
blushing whenever I see new content of
her I'm so
I did the Emojis this yeah melting the
melting and the Moon
that's sweet though that's cute thank
you the things I would let Michael
Evan's bailing due to me
okay is that the emotion that's the
other side that was the Emojis
I will lick Daniel Ezra's sweat I don't
care they are I'm so glad I'm not a guy
these are nasty these are nasty
nasty thoughts
if Samantha Logan said she wants to step
on my neck there it is there it is I'd
literally lay down flat on the floor and
let her do just that
if if that's what you want
oh what I mean you after a long day I
think that you I'm just trying to
accommodate it's what the people want
that's
that's okay not to be dramatic but I
would do anything
to have George Baker as my baby daddy
[Laughter]
can have whatever part of me he likes
then give Michael Bailey the rest
should I leave what part don't you want
you just get like the toes
holy [ __ ] Olivia Baker is a goddamn
smoke show and I wanted to have my
children yes I know I'm late but [ __ ] it
smokes
what it's a goddamn smoke
it's a goddamn smoke smoke I think what
did I say smoke show that's probably
right did I say show you said the show
Jordan Baker can help me bake his kids
bake inside me lol after marriage of
course oh she saved it okay okay yeah we
went okay that's a little bit of Heaven
and Hell
Spencer James could fold me up like a
pretzel he'd been fine as [ __ ] since
season four wait
in season four so one two and three I
went [ __ ] one two and three you were
subpar apparently hey you know Sky girl
on my head
the way I'd suck up
Jordan Baker Mr Spencer and
Darnell from All American yeah I'm just
a whole choo choo
I want to sit on Daniel Ezra's face
period
what what
all right all right you just began mean
bro you just became an internet that's
it for you that's it for you that's
gonna follow you until this show is done
I just want Samantha Logan to disrespect
me
and chores
so sorry there you go the more I watch a
whole American the more I want to lick
Jordan Baker and Spencer James like a
[ __ ] lollipop
the yawn face
my doctor told me I wasn't allowed to
have dairy
but he didn't say anything about nuts
he said but he didn't say anything about
nut
dot dot s I'm gonna give you that one
that's that's that's hard
that's hot that's that's hard
Samantha Logan is so hot I want to eat
my arms
Jordan Baker is a fine ass specimen like
it's just not right
that he's not under me right now hashtag
all-americans
I would literally suck the life out of
Daniel Ezra's dick
there's no like metaphor there's no the
fact that someone tweeted this there's
no vagueness that's what I want straight
okay okay
straight to the point Samantha Logan can
get her ass a there you go
foreign
[Laughter]
thank you thank you for watching yes
thank you thank you for watching this
thank you for watching the show uh
y'all look gross appreciate it we
appreciate your grossness oh take me
home oh no literally get me out of here
[Music]
[Music]